good afternoon
there comes a point in every conference
where somebody stands up and takes a
contrary view
we've just reached it
i don't recognize what i hear about the
open trade that i've heard today
i do absolutely understand the problems
that we all face and i'll go into those
but i think that we are much further
ahead in the game than you think we are
i need to address three quickly three
points raised by the previous speaker
the idea of a register is already there
it's called vat
i have to keep a registration of every
object i buy
from whom i bought it how i paid
and i can assure you that the tax people
are much more onerous than the antiques
department of the met
secondly
we have rigorous due diligence
guidelines which absolutely
fit in with what he wanted there
in fact it's a requirement of membership
of our trade association that every
object that is to be sold for more than
3 000 euros must be checked with the
interpol database and indeed other
commercial databases
export licenses
this sounds so good doesn't it you can't
get anything into german unless it's got
an export license well this is all very
well but if i tell you that i purchased
the mustachy collection which was
exported from license under license from
egypt in 1947 over a period of 15 years
and the export license over 10 000
objects and the export license said 15
cases of antiques
it's not a very helpful document
we've talked a lot
today about looted art
but it must be clear to all of us that
the greatest crisis currently facing the
world heritage is the destruction taking
place in syria and iraq
the major causes of the destruction are
twofold
war with indiscriminate shelling and
bombing
and deliberate destruction of monuments
by fanatics in the name of their
religion
looting comes a poor third
recent lurid headlines have suggested
that the funding of isis through the
sale of illicitly excavated antiquities
is the foremost problem and actively
encouraged by the trade
this is completely untrue
wild speculation that tens of millions
sometimes even billions of pounds worth
of antiquities are entering the market
from syria is common
no one with any knowledge of the market
would give a moment's credence to these
ideas
although we have no doubt and
acknowledge that amidst the destruction
there is a lot of clandestine excavation
looting taking place
there's no evidence to date of any
significant material surfacing on the
market
in any event the licit market is small
and the vast majority of antiquities
have relatively modest value
best estimates and i'm happy to produce
figures to back this up for you these
are facts this is not speculation
best estimates show the global annual
turnover of the open market for
classical and pre-classical antiquities
is less than 200 million euros per annum
the proportion of that consisting of
objects from syria is a small fraction
probably less than 10 percent
the illicit market must necessarily be
smaller than that since pieces which are
elicit sooner or later invariably turn
up
and as an ex-soldier i can attest that
some sort of sums of money we're talking
about don't buy many arms so the idea
that isis is being paid for with roman
tier bottles worth two hundred dollars
each is complete trash
at this point i need to emphasize the
difference between the licit trade and
illegal traffic
the illicit antiquities trade has no
interest in the illegal traffic in
stolen antiquities
the preservation of our ancient heritage
is as vital to us as it is to anyone
else here
the fact that we come from a different
perspective a commercial perspective
does not mean that our reverence for
world cultural heritage is any less real
than yours
indeed at its best the trade is a
positive force devoting large resources
to conservation and research
the earliest roots of archaeology
started with collectors the first museum
was founded by a collector
it's the jobs of museums to collect and
conserve for the benefit of the public
and this is impossible without a trade
the trade has not always had a good
record in the past in dealing with
smuggled material
but things have changed dramatically in
the last 10 to 15 years and continue to
do so
our trade associations have actively
collaborated with government in this
country to address these issues
i also acknowledge that much of this
change has been driven by our critics
yet they should also acknowledge that in
recent years we've made huge strides
no other area of the art market now
prizes provenance more than we do
and the proof of this lies in the high
price at auction fetched by those
objects with fine demonstrable ownership
history
but we too rely on information and this
is rarely forthcoming from source
countries or indeed from our own
authorities
sometimes this is because of
misplaced sense of pride
sometimes uh because of lassitude
sometimes it must be said because of
corruption
even close to home we're deliberately
denied access to information
earlier on was mentioned the so-called
bikina archive
named after a man who hasn't even been
convicted
and this archive is jealously guarded by
an academic in cambridge and morsels of
information drip fed
how on earth are we supposed to conduct
our necessary due diligence in the face
of this attitude
okay that's the past now let's talk
about the future
the real question for all of us is how
much can be salvaged from these wars and
by what means
what is needed is not breast beating and
demonization of the trade
but new and accurate data that provides
better grounds for answering these
questions
it is for governments and international
organizations to source this information
and to pass it on to those on the ground
including law enforcement museums and we
ourselves the trade
but this information must be based on
facts and not on speculation
only then can we halt or reduce
smuggling on the borders of these
countries
and perhaps attention at this point
should be targeted on the countries
directly bordering the conflict zones
it is our belief that much of the
material that is being looted in syria
today is not even leaving the country or
if it is it must be going to countries
that are very close
in the near east
so can the trade help in all this we
obviously can't help on border patrols
there's no doubt that amidst the
destruction illicit material is being
squirreled away as i say
this really worries us
as this material will necessarily
surface on the open market sooner or
later
and this could be some years from now
the challenge therefore is to identify
it
and where possible to return it when
it's safe to do so we all agree on that
it is clear that the help of the trade
is going to be vital in confronting this
problem and it will
require a long-term collaboration
those critics of the trade who find
themselves unable to work with us should
perhaps ask themselves if this attitude
is really in the greater interest
it should be clear to you all following
recent events who your enemy really is
it isn't us
the key to the problem lies in
information
the technology now exists to record
objects cheaply and we would suggest
that unesco should provide the support
to allow vulnerable museums and in
particular off-site storage facilities
to photograph all their holdings
once an object is recorded the chances
of recovery improve to an enormous
extent
the same applies to above-ground
archaeological sites
this is of course no help in the case of
clandestine excavation but it's a start
the issue can also be tackled from
another direction
my trade association is working on a
project which is intended to record
objects which are on the market in
perpetuity
this is intended to build up a database
of those objects which can be legally
traded without question
while providing an opportunity for
potential claimants to identify those
which are stolen
this is a huge demonstration of good
faith
and it will also make life much more
difficult for those who deal illegally
and make no mistake we talk about new
laws being needed but this is illegal to
deal in stolen antiquities from syria is
already illegal it's something for which
you can be jailed no sensible dealer
wants to get involved in that
we're willing and ready to play our part
which we regard as a vital one
and i say to you that if you want to
suppress the black market you should
support the white
and that would include allowing more
freedom of movement for legally held
objects
less border controls less export
requirements or have export requirements
but actually give export licenses for
heaven's sake why not if somebody's
owned a piece in italy for a hundred
years why shouldn't they be able to sell
it on the world market why do they have
to go through this ferrago every time
and everything is blocked
so support the white trade and you will
attack the black
finally i have to say that the best way
of curtailing all this mayhem
would be by returning the region to
peace
we all know that
and at least we dealers can't be blamed
for the war
that is something that our governments
have to think about
and by the way i might mention that
before the iraq war the second iraq war
i wrote to tony blair
begging him to put a tank in front of
the museum once they took baghdad
i got no reply
of course the british postal system is
very unreliable
the first thing i heard from the
government was a letter from them
once the baghdad museum had been looted
asking me what my trade association was
going to do to stop this stuff coming on
the market and i have to say that my my
answer to that was pretty anglo-saxon
when i think of nimrod i feel like
weeping
i've never been there
and now i never will
i have saved 15 seconds
of my allotted time
for us to just think about nimrod
rip